what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and in this video
i will be explaining the backstory
of every single student from class 1a
using all of the information that we
have available so far
class 1a is full of interesting
characters with compelling backstories
and even though we know more about some
of the students than we do about others
i thought that it would be useful to
gather all of that information right
here in one video
for your convenience if you enjoyed the
mha content on this channel and you want
us to keep it going do me a favor
and leave a like and comment it only
takes a second
and it's a completely free way to
directly support this channel
and of course if you're new to anime
opera or maybe you watch our videos but
you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications a big thank you to all
of our anime uproar patrons who make
long and time consuming videos like this
one possible i will
talk more about patreon at the end of
the video but first a note
for anime onlys in this video i've done
my best to avoid
big spoilers while still keeping the
essence of each backstory
that said the manga is far ahead of the
anime so if you are super sensitive to
all spoilers
this is your warning let's start it off
with the student who sits in seat number
one
yuga aoyama aoyama was born in france
although his name suggests that he is
ethnically japanese
or at least that one of his parents is
japanese the connection to france
explains why aoyama likes to
eccentrically scream out french words
at random times and i've actually heard
him referred to as a
abu so like a weeaboo but for french
culture instead of japanese
and you know what i actually think
that's pretty hilarious and kind of
accurate
but despite his over-the-top persona
that is full of life and
twinkles aoyama actually had a very
difficult
childhood when his quirk first started
to manifest at a young age
some sort of birth defect led to
aoyama's laser beams
leaking out of his navel this made him
feel like an outcast and like something
was wrong with him
i imagine that the other children were
probably scared of him because they
didn't want him to accidentally shoot
lasers at them
which must have made aoyama feel
extremely isolated and lonely he even
asked his parents why he was so
different from everyone else
and why he had to deal with such pain
and loneliness
thankfully aoyama eventually received a
special belt that allowed him to control
his quirk and prevent the lasers from
leaking out
and he still wears this special belt
known as the sparkle belt
every single day at first glance aoyama
may come off as an overconfident elitist
who thinks he is better than everyone
else
but this is just his way of compensating
for the inferiority complex that he
developed
during his difficult childhood next up
let's talk about the student who sits in
seat number two
our girl pinky aka mina ashido
mina comes from chiba prefecture in
japan and she and kirishima actually
went to the same
middle school even back in her middle
school days mina was strong
and confident and she was considered to
be a shoe-in for becoming a future pro
hero
by all her classmates mina was the kind
of person who stood up to bullies and
showed great bravery when it came to
protecting her friends
one day when she and her friends had
accidentally encountered gigantomachia
on the street
mina was the only one who summed up the
courage to speak to him
her friends were all terrified by this
giant man who was clearly aggressive and
prone to violence
but mina summed up the courage to trick
him into leaving her
and her friends alone kirishima actually
witnessed
this incident from a distance as well as
a previous incident in which mina
diffused a bullying situation
and this inspired kirishima to become a
better person
and a better hero so yeah mina actually
played an important role
in shaping kirishima into the person
that he is today
in seat number three we have tsuyu asui
aka froppy born in aichi prefecture
tsuyu grew up as the oldest of three
siblings she has a younger brother
and a younger sister and because her
parents traveled a lot for
work tsuyu was largely the one
responsible for raising her siblings
even though she herself
was still just a child but despite
having so much responsibility thrown at
her at such a young age
tsuyu never complained and she loved her
siblings and her life
but because she was always busy taking
care of her siblings
and because some people didn't like her
frog-like appearance
tsuyu didn't really have friends but
then she met habukomangus
a girl at her middle school who also had
no friends because of her snake-like
appearance which seemed to scare most
people
tsuyu recognized that habuko was lonely
just like she was
so one day tsuyu asked habuko to be
friends
habuko was surprised but she was also
delighted and the two of them became
friends they remained close throughout
middle school
and even though they ended up going to
different schools they are still friends
and they still stay
in touch tsuyu also remains close with
her younger siblings and she stays in
touch with them
on a regular basis in seat number four
we have the stern
and morally upright class representative
tenya
ida tenya is from tokyo and he was born
into the prestigious
ida family which has produced successful
pro heroes for generations
the idas are known for their engine
based speed quirks
and because of his prestigious lineage
tenya attended a private school before
joining the ua
tenya was especially inspired by his
older brother tensei
who became the famous pro hero in genium
tenya
always looked up to his brother and it
was tenya's admiration of tensei that
motivated him to be responsible
disciplined and work hard to become a
pro hero
tanya was devastated after tensei was
critically wounded by the hero killer
stain
tensei survived but he was left
paralyzed by his injuries
and he was forced to retire from being a
hero tenya then inherited his older
brother's hero name
ingenium next up we have the student in
seat number five
ochako uraraka she was born in mia
prefecture in the kansai region of japan
and her parents own a construction
business unfortunately
ochoko's parents construction business
has been suffering
and so the family has been facing some
financial hardship
but despite these financial issues
ochoko's parents were always loving and
caring towards her
and so ochako decided that she wanted to
help her parents in fact
ochako offered to use her gravity quirk
to help with the family business
since her ability to make large objects
weightless
would be an immense advantage in any
construction project
however ochako's parents wanted their
daughter to follow her
own dreams so instead of asking her to
dedicate herself to helping the
struggling family business
they encouraged her to pursue her own
dream of becoming a hero
ochako agreed because she really wanted
to help people but she also hopes to
earn enough money as a pro hero to ease
the financial burden
of her parents in seat number six is
mashirao ojiro
also known as the guy whose quirk is
just having a big tail
i mean his quirk is literally just named
tail so yes
he has a tail that's it we don't have a
lot of information about ojiro's life
before he entered ua
we just know that he was born in tokyo
and that he has a background in martial
arts
that actually makes perfect sense since
ojiro's quirk doesn't have any cool
special powers
or abilities it's just an extra
appendage but
using martial arts allows ojiro to make
the best of his quirk by turning it
into a valuable tool in combat then we
have our boy
electric saitama also known as denki
kaminari who sits in seat number seven
coincidentally kaminari was born in
saitama prefecture
and we know that he craves positive
attention from other people especially
from girls
kaminari prioritizes socializing to his
academic studies
and he is very concerned with his public
image but even though kaminari would
love to be the coolest guy in class
he often does things that end up making
him look silly rather than cool
in seat number eight is the manliest of
hero students
ijiro kirishima like mina hirishima
is from chiba prefecture and as i
mentioned earlier
the two of them went to the same middle
school kirishima's hardening quirk
first manifested when he was only three
years old one night he woke up to pee
in the middle of the night and when he
rubbed his eyes his quirk suddenly
manifested on his hand
and the resulting injury left a scar on
his right
eye this traumatic first experience made
kirishima hate his quirk
at least initially as a kid kirishima
idolized the chivalrous hero
crimson riot who also possesses a
hardening type quirk
just like kirishima crimson riot
stresses the importance of having a
manly spirit
and being willing to train hard
regardless of how strong your quirk
is and so kirishima embraced this
philosophy
and used it as motivation to make
himself stronger hirishima knew mina in
middle school
and this was a period of his life in
which he lacked courage and confidence
mina's bravery and strong personality
inspired kirishima
and eventually he decided to change his
entire image including dying his hair
red to look more like crimson riot
kirishima eventually adopted the hero
name
red riot as a tribute to his favorite
hero
next up is koji koda also known as the
petting hero anima who sits in seat
number
nine koda hails from iwate prefecture
and he is a shy and quiet guy who
appears to be more comfortable around
nature and animals than around
humans in fact koda is so quiet that
even though class 1a was first
introduced in chapter 5
of the manga koda doesn't have his first
line of dialogue until
chapter 66. koda's quirk gives him the
ability to communicate with
and command animals but ironically
he has an extreme fear of bugs this
proves to be a challenge for koda at
first
because manipulating bugs could be a
very useful ability
if only he can overcome his phobia of
bugs
we don't know much more about his
backstory other than the fact that he
has a loving
mother who is very proud and supportive
of her son
then we have rikidosato also known as
sugarman who sits in seat number 10.
sato was born in the tottori prefecture
of japan
and we know that he is a very skilled
baker baking is of course related to his
quirk
sugar rush but it also appears to be
somewhat of a passion for sato
however when his classmates pointed out
just how good his baking was
satos seemed surprised since he didn't
think that his baking skills were
anything special this might suggest that
he comes from a baking family
perhaps baking is his family's business
and so sato grew up comparing himself to
other skilled bakers in his family
and that is why he doesn't think that
his own skills are anything special
that is just speculation though because
we really don't know much about sato's
backstory
at this point in time in seat number 11
we have
mezo shoji who was born in fukuoka
prefecture
we know that shoji is not materialistic
and that he is fine with having
only a few possessions this suggests
that he comes from a family of modest
means
and that he likely had a very humble
childhood we also know that growing up
shoji faced prejudice and discrimination
as a result of his unique appearance
shoji's mutant type quirk makes his
appearance permanently different
from that of ordinary people and so
according to shoji
people were often frightened by his
physical appearance
this is why shoji wears a mask over his
face
at all times at one point in his past
the sight of his face had made a little
girl cry
and so shoji decided to always cover his
face so that it never causes sadness to
anyone else
as a result we still have no idea what
shoji actually looks like beneath his
mask
this in itself is pretty sad shoji feels
like he has to cover his face for the
sake of others
but the fact that he is willing to do
this in the first place also speaks to
the kind of person that he is
despite his intimidating appearance
shoji
is actually a very kind and
compassionate person
next up is the rock star of class 1a kyo
kajiro who sits in seat number 12.
hailing from shizuoka prefecture kyoka
comes from a family of musicians
and she grew up with music as an
important part of her life
she can sing and play multiple
instruments and her parents were hoping
that kyouka would become a musician like
them but even though kyouka loves
music her dream was to become a hero so
that she could dedicate her life to
helping
other people ultimately kyouka's parents
supported her decision to choose her own
path and become a hero
rather than a musician then we have flex
tape spider-man himself
han tasero who sits in seat number 13.
cerro was born in tokyo and he is a very
friendly and social guy
although he is not as forward about it
as minata and kaminari
sero definitely has a strong interest in
the ladies
and in general he is a fun guy to be
around
although we don't know much about his
background we do know that horikoshi
came up with the idea for his
quirk while shopping in a convenience
store and horikoshi has also stated that
serosquirk
is one of his personal favorites in seat
number 14
we have the one and only chicken of
darkness fumikage
tokoyami comes from shizuoka prefecture
and he is a very quiet reserved and
independent guy
tokoyami has an affinity for darkness
and he is often jokingly referred to as
an
emo by the mha fanbase because of his
fashion sense and his
taste in room decor he is also very
interested in things like fantasy and
the occult
so he's kind of a cool dark emo nerd
we still haven't gotten a proper deep
dive into tokoyami's backstory but we
can assume that his quiet and
introspective personality is a result of
his appearance
and his quirk tokuyami probably faced
prejudice and discrimination for his
bird-like appearance
and since his quirk dark shadow is the
type of quirk that can go berserk
it's likely that some of the other kids
were afraid of tokoyami during his
childhood
as a result tokoyami probably retreated
into himself
and developed his own unique interests
and identity without relying on the
approval of others
next up we have shoto todoroki who sits
in seat number 15
and whose backstory has actually been
explored at great length
shoto's father is of course the former
number two and current number one pro
hero
endeavor shoto also has three
older siblings two brothers and one
sister
shoto's father spent most of his life
desperately trying to surpass all might
and when he eventually realized that
this would be impossible endeavour
decided to find a wife with the ideal
quirk
and then raise children who would one
day surpass all might
so endeavour married rey in what is
known as a quirk
marriage endeavour believed that rey's
ice-based quirk would be an ideal
pairing with his flame-based quirk
and rey's family thought that a union
with the wealthy and prominent todoroki
family
would be a solution to their financial
troubles rey
agreed to the marriage out of a sense of
duty to her family
but this was very much a marriage of
convenience rather than love
after the first three todoroki children
didn't quite possess the ideal quirks
that endeavour was looking for he was
finally satisfied with the quirk of his
fourth child shoto who had the unique
ability to use both fire
and ice endeavor was convinced that
shoto would one day surpass
all might so endeavour separated shoto
from the rest of his siblings
and instead of letting him play with his
brothers and sister endeavour pushed
shoto to train
constantly in order to get stronger in
the process of training shoto
endeavour also neglected his other
children and his relationship with his
wife ray became
strained shoto himself began to resent
his father because of his treatment of
rey
and also because he wouldn't let shoto
have a normal childhood things only got
worse
after shoto's oldest brother toya was
presumed to have been killed
in a horrible fire the tragedy led
endeavour to focus even more obsessively
on training shoto
and it also led rey to lose her mental
stability after rey suffered a mental
breakdown and poured boiling water on
shoto's face
she ended up in a mental institution
shoto blamed endeavour for everything
that happened to his mother
and to his entire family and he spent
much of his life completely rejecting
his father
for a long time he even refused to use
the flame side of his quirk
because it came from his father but
eventually shoto came to accept
both sides of his quirk and since then
he has made some slow but significant
progress
in reconciling with endeavor then we
have the invisible girl
toru hagakure who sits in seat number
16.
very little is known about toru other
than the fact that she was born in tokyo
and that both of her parents apparently
have the same invisibility type quirk as
she does
toru has a bubbly personality and she
loves to hang out with the class
1a girls gossip about boys go shopping
and all of that fun teenage girl stuff
since toru is permanently invisible
we don't know what she actually looks
like and because her quirk is so perfect
for
covert activities many mha fans believe
that toru might be the ua traitor who is
leaking vital information about the ua
to the league
of villains however there is no real
evidence for this
and the story hasn't really mentioned
the traitor in a long time
so at this point many of us are
wondering whether the traitor thing
is even a thing anymore in seat number
17
we have the legendary lord explosion
murder himself
katsuki bakugo bakugo comes from the
same neighborhood
in shizuoka prefecture as deku does and
the two of them grew up together
deku always looked up to bakugo since
bakugou had a lot of confidence and a
cool explosion quirk that always
impressed everyone
eventually all of that praise went to
bakugo's head
and he became arrogant and sometimes
downright mean
he actually gave izuku midoriya the
nickname deku
but he meant it to be an insult although
deku eventually just
embraced the nickname and even made it
his official hero name
bakugo was also a big fan of almight
just like deku
and he aspired to one day become the
kind of ultimate winner
that almight was the young bakugo firmly
believed that a great hero will always
win
no matter what and all might was the
embodiment
of that principle by the time that he
got to middle school
bakugo became an outright bully and he
would often lose his temper and berate
and abuse others
including deku since deku was born
without a quirk
bakugo often mocked deku's ambition to
get into ua and become a hero
so yeah bakugo went through a phase in
which he was an arrogant bully who was
constantly followed around by
butt-kissing
lackeys thankfully he did eventually
emerge out of that phase and develop as
a character
although he continues to have a wild
temper and a short fuse
oh and he has a hot mom yes i said it
no regrets next up in seat number 18
is the protagonist of our story the one
and only izuku midoriya
also known as deku hailing from shizuoka
prefecture just like bakugou
deku began to idolize all might at a
very young
age and it was his greatest dream in
life to become a hero
like all might unfortunately deku was
born without a quirk
in a world where the vast majority of
people possess quirks
this made it almost impossible for deku
to become a hero since
all the other heroes and villains would
possess extremely strong
and useful special abilities and he
would have nothing
the realization that he was quirkless
absolutely crushed
deku but even after realizing that he
didn't have a quirk deku stubbornly
continued to dream about one day
becoming a hero
he dedicated himself to joining the ua
japan's most prestigious school for hero
students
but the very idea of someone without a
quirk joining the ua was so crazy
that deku was often mocked and belittled
for even considering the possibility of
getting accepted into that school
luckily for deku he would eventually
cross paths with almight who chose deku
to be his successor
as a result deku inherited the
transferable quirk one for all
by consuming a strand of almight's hair
and his newfound quirk
combined with his commitment to his
academic studies allowed him to pass the
ua
entrance exam deku has a caring and
extremely loving mother named
inco who worries about him a lot because
being a pro hero
is a dangerous job but at the same time
she is also extremely supportive of her
son's dream
on the other hand deku's father went out
to buy yu-gi-oh cards
and never came back okay not really but
all we know about him is that his name
is
hisashi imidoriya and that he has a fire
breathing quirk
he apparently works abroad and we have
never even
seen him i mean we've never even seen
deku or inco
communicating directly with him in any
way so just your typical shonen
anime dad hailing from kanagawa
prefecture is the man
the myth the legend minoruminata who
sits in seat number 19.
we don't know much about his backstory
but mineta is known for being completely
obsessed with girls and for
easily being the pervious character in
the entire story
it's likely that this type of behavior
started at a young age so we can assume
that minata spent a lot of time surfing
the internet alone
in his room in the dark if you know what
i mean despite being quite intelligent
mineta keeps coming up with stupid pervy
schemes like trying to peek on the girls
in the public bath
but whenever he tries something like
this he ends up getting wrecked and
suffering some serious consequences
i can't help but think that he has a lot
of potential as long as he starts
putting more focus on being a hero
and less focus on perving out minita
really wants to be popular
and loved so he should do his best to
achieve that goal through heroics
and not through trying to unsuccessfully
create his own harem personally
i think it would be hilarious if minata
one day found a girlfriend that was an
even bigger perv than him
come on horikoshi let's make it happen
and finally
we have the undisputed best girl in
class 1a
momo yaoyarozu who sits in seed number
20.
oh and if you disagree with my accurate
opinion that momo is best girl
feel free to rant about it down in the
comments engagement helps this video
anyway momo was born in aichi prefecture
into a very wealthy family the
yaoyarozus are a famous and prominent
hero family with powerful quirks
and momo's quirk creation is no
exception momo
obviously had a very privileged
upbringing due to her family's wealth
but being rich did not make her arrogant
or lazy
momo works extremely hard she is an
excellent student
and she is an expert strategist she puts
a lot of effort
into learning to use her quirk in the
most effective way
and she also puts incredible amounts of
thought into her plans
and strategies momo is also humble
friendly
and all-around best girl material
and that is it all 20 class 1a students
and their backstories explained if you
enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
bocano here content please leave that
like
it means a lot and if you're new to
anime pro or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
i know it's annoying but if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works shout out to
414 anime for helping me out with the
research
for this video check out his anime
channel and show him some love
link in the description a big thank you
to all of our anime opera
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma red
haired raven
and av these guys are absolute
mad lads and disciples of lord twigo
himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
dr cortman the toasted chi bang emperor
otaku spidey life canal tungsten targus
baked buddhist and you know finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel crews anatoly kazatsuki cricket xp
rathune deora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joanne
garcia ted no ted
isparky65 jessica lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pillow if
you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you